[inaudible]
Pearson is kind of like your boss.
You don't like him,
you don't trust him.
But yeah,
absolutely do need him to pay your
bills.
Now,
it's been a long time since we talked
about Putin here on visual politic and I
know what you're thinking now.
Okay.
Again,
Simon,
and we rarely gonna talk about oil.
I mean do it to death.
Why don't you,
well actually this time we're not
talking about oil.
Exactly.
We're talking about natural gas.
Now,
many of you might think that these are
actually very similar things because at
the end of the day,
countries with oil reserves usually have
gas reserves too,
but there is a difference.
Oil markets are way more diversified.
For example,
Europe obeys 30% of their crude oil from
Russia,
but when it comes to the gas,
then number rises to 40% but if we look
at each individual European country,
the dependency is way higher.
Germany imports 60% of their gas from
Russia and other countries like Finland
in the Baltics depends entirely on
Russian gas.
In other words,
Putin could leave these countries
freezing on a cold,
cold wind tonight.
That would honestly make game of thrones
look kind of like Baywatch.
Hold on a minute here because there's
more to this resource than heating in
facts.
We need natural gas for many of the
things.
In fact,
domestic and assumption is just a third
of the
total
as you can see on this chart.
Another third is for thermal power
plants,
but the biggest share is used by various
industries.
For example,
a paper manufacturing company needs
thermal energy.
This means heat in order to get this
eat.
The factory uses gas and the same goes
for many,
many other industries.
In other words,
gas is extremely important to everybody
and that includes Europe and now can you
guess who is the biggest consumer of gas
in all of Europe?
Yup,
of course that would be Germany,
the most populous country on the
continent and also the one with the
largest economy,
and this is the key to our story because
as long as Germany remains so dependent
on Russia,
all of Europe is going to depend on
Russia too.
And this is why during the 2018 NATO
summit,
Donald Trump said things like this,
Germany is totally controlled by Russia
because they were getting from 60 to 70%
of their energy from Russia and a new
pipeline,
and you'd tell me if that's appropriate
because I think it's not then.
I think it's a very bad thing for NATO.
All right,
so the question today is trump,
right when he criticizes Germany,
is it really a problem that Germany has
such a high dependency on Russian gas
and more importantly,
is there a true attempt to reduce that
dependency?
Well,
today we're going to answer all of those
questions,
but as always,
before we do last,
take a look back at the history
man in Berlin,
there are two ways of transporting gas.
The cheapest one is through a pipeline.
This means we build a huge pipe that
goes from the place we take the gas,
see the Yamal peninsula in Russia to the
country that buys it.
For example,
Germany.
This is very cheap because,
yeah,
just need to build the pipelines.
There you go.
There's no need for trucks.
There's no need for ships.
This,
nothing like that.
Since you transport the gas through the
pipes,
it comes to the power plants,
the houses and the factories all
directly.
There is also an alternative method
though,
and that's so called liquified natural
gas or l and g.
So how does this work?
Well,
let's say we take our guests from
cutoff.
What we do is we lowered its temperature
until it's 161 Celsius below zero.
This is the point when the gas becomes
liquid and you can store it in bottles.
These bottles can then be stored on a
ship and sent to say Barcelona in Spain
there they have a regassification plants
where they heat to the liquid until it
becomes gas again.
The gas thing goes to the national pipe
network and that's when it's transported
to houses and factories and things like
that.
So what's the advantage of this process?
Well,
it allows Europe to diversify their gas
providers easily.
But what's the problem?
Uh,
it's 50 to 70% more expensive than using
those pipelines.
We mentioned previously,
and this,
this is why European countries buy their
gas from the closest to producers that
were using pipelines.
For example,
the biggest supplier of Spain is
Algeria,
but the northern countries,
they buy gas from Norway and especially
Russia.
As we said before,
countries like rough snaps or luke,
I'll export more than half of the gas
consumed in Germany and this,
well,
what about the country is located
between Germany and Russia?
Well,
they haven't even deeper dependency.
Just have a look at this.
Yeah.
Wow.
Pay Attention.
You'll see how Poland depends on Russian
gas.
The 75% of its needs.
Other countries like Finland is in
Romania.
They go all the way up to 100%.
In other words,
half of Europe needs Russia in order to
simply survive,
and this is no secret.
The European Commission,
they know about it and believe me,
Vladimir Putin knows about it too.
Germany will become totally dependent on
Russian energy if it does not
immediately change course.
Here in the Western Hemisphere.
We are committed to maintaining our
independence from the encroachment of
expansionist foreign powers.
But
let's pause the video here for just a
moment.
Right here we can see the German
delegation laughing at trump.
He just said that will become totally
dependent on Russian energy.
This means if they were already
dependence,
they will become even more dependence.
So what is he talking about exactly?
Well,
let's rewind the video.
Remember this name?
Gerhard schrader.
Here's the former German chancellor,
the predessessors of Angela Merkel.
He still maintains a massive influence
in German and European politics and
well,
what does he do now?
Well,
actually he's building v
former,
no chief rest Mohsen Germany walks into
Putin's trap,
Nord Stream two basically Nord stream
two is a brand new pipeline,
but we're to go under the Baltic Sea
connecting Germany with Russia with no
middle man with this new pipeline,
Germany could double the import of
Russian gas.
Since this project has a shareholder
committee with companies like the
Russian giant Gazprom and the presidents
of this committee is of course Mr.
Schroeder.
If this isn't enough.
The former German chancellor is also the
president of Ross.
NAFSA rational.
Yeah.
This is wine.
The last 10 years,
Schroeder has become Putin's man in
Europe.
In fact,
he has defended Russia in all kinds of
matters from the cyber attacks against
the Estonian governments do the Crimean
invasion.
In other words,
far from reducing that dependence on
Russia.
Germany is giving him the opposite
direction.
So what were those Germans laughing
about?
Honestly,
I don't have any idea,
but all right.
All right.
I know what you're thinking right now.
What was the problem with depends on
quite so much on Russia.
Maybe it's because Putin's an
authoritarian ruler,
but seriously it's not because if that
was the case or where else would we buy
gas from?
I mean the other list of suppliers
includes as a [inaudible],
Algeria and Qatar,
which of course we all know a healthy
democracy is governed by wonderful
people.
Bullock.
The reality is no one really gives a
shit about democracy and human rights
when it comes to having heating in
[inaudible].
Now,
the problem with defending on Russia is
something else and that's something
you're going to understand right now.
Russia holics in Leah,
2006 Gazprom ones at the Ukrainians to
pay six times more for gas in.
This was a 100% political move for
decades.
Russia and Ukraine had this really good
relationship and then the orange
revolution began when Victor Yushchenko
came to power with his auntie Russian
and pro European rhetoric.
The Kremlin essentially said this or I
Ukraine.
Well,
if you want to go and hang out with your
cool European friends and forget about
us,
well get your wallet out because it's
going to be expensive.
I think about it.
Building a brand new pipeline with
another country,
it takes years,
so Ukraine,
they just couldn't find a new supplier
overnight if booths in one sense,
he could raise prices at well,
men's,
if you crane doesn't want to pay us
well,
Russia or we'll just close the pipe
for three days in the middle of a cold
wave,
Ukrainians had no heating at home and
after a tense negotiation,
Ukraine agreed to pay double for the gas
exchange.
It raised the fee that Russia had to pay
in order to cross the country,
transport the gas to the rest of Europe
bus.
This was just the beginning.
In the year 2009 we had the same problem
but rather king sized.
Russia wanted Ukraine to pay more for
their gas.
Once again,
Kevin Moscow started insulting each
other and in this case it was not only
Ukraine,
the one without gas for days,
it was also the rest of Europe and that
included the Czech Republic,
Italy,
Poland's and of course Germany.
Yes,
dear us,
most of that Russian gas comes through
Ukraine,
so if Ukrainians have no gas to the
Johnson's are other Europeans are going
to be freezing too.
Again,
the story ends with Ukraine paying more
for their gas in exchange for more
transport fees.
Nevertheless,
just like game of thrones,
Putin's tune is a song of ice and fire
after freezing Europeans in 2006 and
2009 2014 when it was the year of fire
and the fire came in a Ukrainian
province,
core Crimea
because as you know,
Russians took it and so what did the
European Union doing this case?
Well,
they just came to Peterson and
essentially said,
who's in your very naughty boy?
We're going to sanction you.
When do you all write these lines?
20 Times over?
I will not invade other countries.
Now Ukraine is more of a headache than
anything else,
but that's something we're going to
cover in the next video of this series
because yes,
we all doing a series all about Russian
gas.
And if you don't want to miss it,
well you know what to do this,
this of dry and below in a ballad,
do your thing.
So now Europe has two options.
Putin,
Andy Schrader,
they want to build new pipelines to
bypass Ukraine.
That is the first option.
The second one is what the European
Union once and that's defined other gas
suppliers,
but well,
can they really do that now pay
attention because we're going to answer
that question.
Attempts to diversify.
The fastest way of diversifying is,
you guessed it,
buying liquefied natural gas.
Now it is expensive,
but countries do not need to wait to
build new pipelines.
So what's the problem there?
Well,
LNG ships are too busy with the Asian
market,
basically.
Great.
The Pacific Ocean is full of these ships
that can go from Australia,
Qatar,
and to Malaysia to Japan,
China.
Okay.
Yeah.
You see in Asia,
gas prices are higher than anywhere
else.
So Good Luck convincing America rock
guitar to sell you.
Then natural gas when they're getting
rich off Asia.
This is why the most realistic option is
to build new pipelines.
The question is though,
wow,
so on the one hands,
we have no way.
This Europe already buys all of the gas
they produce.
Going south,
we have Spain who wants to build the
midcap pipeline that would connect to
Algeria with northern Europe,
but France is not very excited about the
idea because that would mean they have
to build the whole that in order to sell
to other countries.
Um,
well,
you know,
Oh man,
this is so much walk.
Maybe tomorrow or maybe never.
Maybe never.
Never.
Sounds good.
All right.
So then we have serious alternative so
far as the so called Trans Adriatic
pipeline or tap.
This is meant to be finished by 2020.
This pipeline goes from Azerbaijan
crosses Turkey and goes all the way into
Italy.
But wait a minute,
because this still is not enough.
This pipeline has a maximum capacity of
20 billion cubic meters of gas.
This isn't even a half the capacity of
the Nord Stream two that connects
Germany and Russia.
But this is not the only problem when it
comes to oil.
Putin is a fairy jealous boyfriends.
And if you thought he would put up with
so much gas promiscuity when you're very
wrong.
Gas
promises,
gas transit via Ukraine to Europe may
fall to 10 to 15 billion cubic meters
per year.
With this move,
Putin kills two birds with one stone.
Firsties forcing Europe to follow him
and on top of that he bypasses Ukraine.
But this is not the end of the story
here in the south.
Putin is also pushing to build brand new
pipes.
And yesterday if it was,
if you thought Gerhard Schroeder is the
only friend of Vladimir Putin in Europe,
well you're all very,
very good.
Rome hungry
once Russia's Turkish stream pipeline to
be extended into Europe.
But still there are two points we
haven't dealt with her for one,
we have to talk about Ukraine.
Can Putin totally bypass them on top of
that,
we should definitely talk about as a
budget on another dictatorship that will
become Europe's best friend.
So if you don't want to miss those
stories,
do you subscribe to this channel?
Meanwhile,
I've got a question for you.
Do you think Putin can reduce its
dependency on Russia or do you think
Putin will become the night king with
enough power to turn Europeans into
white walkers?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
Also,
do you visit the reconsider media
podcast,
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine?
And if you like this video,
give it a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics in here,
more my lovely voice.
Don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com and we
consider it as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context.
But we don't do the thinking.